僕は一回も使ったことないんですけど
YouTubeでよくリスナーという言葉を聞きます
リスナーとは
Listen
聴く人でリスナーと言います
YouTubeって
耳だけじゃねぇだろ！！
目と耳と心でYouTube感じようや
あ、はじめしゃちょーです
はいというわけで今年も、もうわずかになってしまいました
見てください僕の髪型
なんとかしたい
というわけで今日は僕の髪の毛をなんとかしようと思います
実はですね僕明日ちょっとイベントがあるので
イベントで皆さん来てくれるので
それなりにねちょっとオリジナリティー溢れるというか
やっぱどうせ来てくれんだったら楽しんでほしいので
僕は特にパフォーマンスとかできることもないので
髪型だけでも楽しませようと思います
いくぞ
今年はね最初は赤髪だったんですけど
途中からずっとこういう感じの色で
ゆるーくいってきたんで
年末くらいバシッとね奇抜な髪型にしようと思いますよ
エナジーブリーチ
うううｎ
はいというわけでこれくらい
そんなねそんなね暗くもないんですよ
今これくらいかな？
全然ここら辺まで明るくなります
髪の毛を黄色にしてから色を入れます
どんな色にするかはちょっとねお楽しみというわけで
ひとまず髪の毛の色を抜いちまおう全部
話はそこからだ
よしやるぞー
OK
よし
OK、塗ります
中が黒いから中をしっかり塗りたいですね
ふーーーあーーあーーーやばい出た
よし
これでしばらく放置したら金髪になります
では
いやこれからですよ
これからですからね
これからですよ僕の髪型が変わるのは
とりあえず金金真ッ金金金なったので
ここに色を付けていきます
これを使ってな
これは何かと言っちゃうとバレちゃうんで
この色を入れて僕は今日イベントに行ってきます
今までにない色ですから
きっと来てくださった皆さんも楽しんでくれることでしょう
うん、きっと大好評、間違いない
じゃあ早速色入れてくぜ
ヒャッハー皆殺しだ
はいというわけで完成しましたー
パチパチパチパチ
ちょっとまだねホント見た瞬間のインパクトを与えたいので
この髪型まだ見せないですよ
この髪型で今日はイベントに行ってこようと思います
ファンの皆様に感謝を込めて
皆を笑顔にさせていきたいと思います
では行ってきます
（超フリーダムなYouTubeクリエイター）
（実験系をメインにオールジャンルでなんでもしたいことを動画にしており）
（体を張ったネタや）
（誰もしないような斬新で手の込んだ動画で若年層より圧倒的な支持を得ています）
740人だるまさんが転んだで皆さんご存知
2015年10月ギネス記録を取得しました
はじめしゃちょーーー
はいというわけでこんな髪型にしてみました
コッチ側が赤で
こっちが青でございます
太陽と月のイメージでございます
ポケットモンスターサン＆ムーン是非遊んでみてください
どうしよ
後ろどうなってんのかな
どうなってます？
僕適当にやったんで後ろわかんないんすよね
どうなってましたか